there's an extraordinarily disturbing
report out which says that the
Republican National Committee's using
campaign donations from Republicans to
pay for the legal fees of various Trump
associates related to the Trump Russia
scandal there's a report in The
Washington Post which says that more
than half a million bucks has been spent
on legal expenses of Trump staffers
including remember hope Hicks who
shortly after being interviewed by
Robert molars investigation resigned
from her position as White House
communications director she has major
legal fees she only has according to one
report a net worth of two hundred
thousand dollars which will get eaten up
very quickly when all of a sudden you're
asked to speak to the House Committee
investigating Trump Russia the Senate
committee investigating Trump Russia and
Robert molars team you can go through
two hundred thousand dollars very very
quickly when those are the types of
lawyers that you need and the problem
right now is that donor money donated i
I think if you're a Republican and you
donate to the RNC you're doing it to get
Republicans elected right and apparently
some RNC officials thought you know
maybe it makes more sense to create a
separate legal defense fund specifically
for helping Trump associates pay for
their lawyers but the RNC decided
legally they can do it either way
regardless of whether morally they can
do it and if I'm a Republican donor and
I'm donating to help Republican
candidates and my money is going to Hope
Hicks's lawyer I don't think I'm
particularly happy I mean I guess you
could say maybe you you would think if
you're a Republican
if Republicans go down because of the
investigation
it hurts Republicans at large so I'm ok
with my money going to I don't even I
mean it's not believable to me I'm
trying to come up with a splint nation
but if I'm donating to get Republicans
elected I'm not donating to cover hope
Hicks is legal expenses and I remember
in the midst of the Michael Flynn
indictment his family set up like a
GoFundMe page yes my sense is that
didn't do too well because who wants to
contribute to Michael Michael Flynn in
his legal defense I guess this is just a
roundabout way of doing it because
people are willing to contribute to the
RNC I guess but the thing is it's not
exactly honest that's the problem and if
you're a traditional Republican and you
think that Trump and his cronies are a
group of crook
and you find out your donations are
being used to pay for their lawyers I
don't even know what you do right you
probably don't start voting for
Democrats most Republicans wouldn't do
that what exactly do you do and just for
a second can you imagine if it turned
out that the DNC was paying the legal
fees of like humi Abbadon
for something that she allegedly did in
connection with Hillary Clinton's emails
yes something right that Weiner or
Anthony Weiner like it would be outrage
from the 24/7 right-wing media news
cycle and of course they don't care at
all about this going on I don't even
know that it's been reported at all and
it was also reported a few months ago
just as a footnote to this story
we were told Trump was going to start
paying for his own legal bills because
at this point who knows how many lawyers
Trump needs that also hasn't happened
and I'd love to get an answer on that
I'm sure if you ask Sarah Huckabee
Sanders she'd say that's outside of her
scope that's a question for Trump's
personal lawyers if you ask his personal
lawyers they're certainly not gonna tell
you who's paying them so there's really
no way to figure out like why isn't
Trump paying for his own fees are we
even sure that Trump pays his own
lawyers I mean Michael Cohen had to
apparently pay that $130,000 hush
payment out of pocket right question one
is where is Trump's legal fee money
coming from second question is is Trump
even paying his lawyers because we know
that that was something that kept a lot
of lawyers away from representing the
guy because they thought number one he
wouldn't actually listen to their advice
which we've seen be absolutely true over
the last six months and they were
worried that Trump just wouldn't pay
because he has a history of not mentors
or lawyers or whoever else this is what
is happening within the Republican Party
right now and it still doesn't guarantee
defeat for them in November of 2018
despite all of this stuff going on they
still could maintain control of the
House and Senate which is why it's
really important that everybody vote at
the beginning of the show I said young
progressives Millennials need to vote
they have a pathetically low voter
turnout rate prove everybody wrong and
get out and vote in November they can
still retain control if we don't get out
there and vote